okay so phase three will give us ant-man
and doctor strange is looking good who
else do you want to see
i just want to get deadpool already
not gonna happen he's tied up with fox
all right i would like to really see the
runaways up on screen
that'd be cool
no but i've got my fingers crossed for
civil war
i just don't understand why we're still
waiting on wonder woman that's dc kathy
we're talking marvel whatever they don't
have a single solo chick of note they're
all part of the team
you got storm x-men black widow avengers
even electra can't get out of
daredevil's shadow that's fair
what about she-hulk whose very name is
derivative of her more important male
counterpart really you're gonna use that
you break off your hypothetical film
wanking so this one can make a move oh
she's grouchy when she's losing no i
just know that superhero movies are on
borrowed time
what reality are you living in the
bottom's gonna drop out
the bottom always drops out it happened
to biblical epics westerns musicals and
superhero movies are next
sure there'll be a straggler or two in a
revival in a few decades but eventually
all interests will drop out after
avengers 3. just watch
don't you have somewhere you have to be
yes you're right
thanks sweetie
what no come on i second that negative
you guys are always on me for dating
non-geeks well she's a geek
she's not a geek she's an intellectual
snob
she likes sci-fi
we like sci-fi
she turns her nose up about the wars and
treks of the star variety in favor of
2001 a space odyssey and goddamn primer
she's a snob
you're just jealous of what
oh by the way
night to night three me
okay
maybe i could be on board with this
you